einen schönen guten tag und willkommen
zu heute live ja es war eine lange nacht
in der tat für den cdu-bundesparteitag
stand man hat entschieden nach
mitternacht irgendwann 46 personen im
vorstand waren abstimmungsberechtigt und
das ergebnis war 31 für laschet denn
darum geht es ja die k-frage die
kandidatenfrage in der union 31 also für
laschet 9 für söder und sechs
enthaltungen
so und jetzt ist die frage ist damit
jetzt die kuh vom eis ist die sache
geklärt wie wird sich csu parteichef
markus söder dazu verhalten er hat
angekündigt dass er in wenigen minuten
nämlich genau genommen um 12 eine
pressekonferenz geben wird wir schauen
mal auf die örtlichkeit da ist
allerdings von markus söder noch nichts
zu sehen aber wir haben natürlich eine
auge drauf wie gesagt gegen 12 uhr ist
er angekündigt und die zeit bis dahin
wollen wir gerne füllen wir sprechen
gleich mit unserer kolleginnen in berlin
mit nicole diekmann wollen feuerwehr
noch mal schauen auf die ereignisse der
vergangenen nacht alexandra vacano tut
das für uns ein riss geht durch die
union auch im bundesvorstand gestern
abend ringen um die k-frage die ein
sprechen sich für laschet aus andere
berichten von der basis die prosa sei
die atmosphäre aufgeheizt unklar ob und
wie abgestimmt werden soll inklusive
technischer pannen ein schlagabtausch
über die stimmung in den ländern
insgesamt hat es eine sehr intensive
sehr ernsthafte und auch sehr direkte
aussprache gegeben und dabei ist ein
durchaus diversifiziert ist ein sehr
unterschiedliches bild zum tragen
gekommen das vielleicht interessanteste
war heute wir haben ja immer geglaubt
dass der osten quasi söder land ist das
ist nicht so seit mindestens zwei
landesverbände brandenburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern geben die
berichtet haben nein wir sind klar für
armin laschet
jetzt also die frage wie das söder lager
reagiert mit seinem machtanspruch hatte
der csu chef die cdu vor sich
hergetrieben
aber gestern die entscheidung in die
hände der großen schwester gelegt wenn
die cdu heute abend souverän eine klare
entscheidung trifft dann werden wir das
akzeptieren das habe ich jetzt glaube
ich drei vier mal gesagt insofern also
ja wir sind auch die kleinere schwester
wir können hier ums überleben
heute nachmittag dann die erste
bewährungsprobe für laschet die nächste
sitzung der cdu und csu fraktion in der
schon von kampfabstimmung die rede war
das bedeutet also dass eine große last
von der fraktion genommen ist und es
bedeutet auch dass markus söder gestern
eindeutig gesagt hat er wird ein
eindeutiges votum der großen schwester
wie er sagte akzeptieren das heißt also
die reihen der union schließen sich
hinter armin laschet punktsieg laschet
ob sich die reihen hinter ihm
tatsächlich schließen und der machtkampf
damit wirklich entschieden ist das wird
sich jetzt zeigen ja in der tat das ist
die spannende frage inwieweit wird csu
chef markus söder mit diesem ergebnis
umgehen können inwieweit wird er es
akzeptieren und auch darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit nicole diekmann in berlin
nicole die frage liegt auf dem tisch wie
ist eine einschätzung
also wenn wir gestern abend noch mal
sehr anschaulich etwas lernen konnten
dann wie mitteilungsfreudig die
mitglieder des bundesvorstands sind es
wurde quasi in echtzeit getwittert von
einigen kollegen da ist wie nach außen
gedrungen und dieselben quellen melden
jetzt im laufe des vormittags dass
markus jordan 13 12 tschuldigung zum
einen das schon eine vorverlegt eine
pressekonferenz geben wird also jetzt
gleich das markus söder sich dem votum
des cdu bundesvorstands tatsächlich
beugen wird und das bedeutet dann dass
armin laschet tatsächlich als
kanzlerkandidat ins rennen geht für cdu
und csu
wie ist das einzuschätzen was glaubst du
was hat jetzt letztlich in den ausschlag
gegeben dann ist war ja doch sehr lange
sehr umstritten wir wissen immer noch
nicht hundertprozentig aber wie gesagt
die anzeichen verdichten sich dass es
jetzt auf laschet hinausläuft was war
das entscheidende
ja das ist die große frage die sich hier
heute neben der ob sie da jetzt
tatsächlich klein beigibt und sich dem
votum beugt was ihnen jetzt doch dazu
bewogen hat nach einer woche machtkampf
ein zu denken und sich so demütig wie
wir es ja auch gerade im beitrag gesehen
haben als er von der großen schwester
der cdu spricht was ja stimmt
zu geben es gibt die vermutung von
beobachtern dass wolfgang schäuble cdu
grande da eine nicht unwesentliche rolle
gespielt hat er hat sich vergangene
woche schon offen belastet ausgesprochen
und hat wohl auch in den vergangenen
tagen betont solche la stellt in diesem
machtkampf jetzt über unterliegen dass
er nicht cdu chef bleiben könne und das
wäre auch für die csu eine katastrophe
geworden so angeschlagen dann mit wem
auch immer in den wahlkampf zu ziehen
also der worst case sozusagen aus
laschet sicht ist jetzt erstmal so
scheint es abgewendet aber man muss er
trotzdem sagen wenn man sich jetzt das
votum anschaut 46 personen 31 pro
laschet 9 immerhin klar pro schüler und
sechs enthaltungen das ist ja für cdu
verhältnisse jetzt kein überragendes
ergebnis also ist die cdu gespalten
also eigentlich ist sie sich nicht
besonders interessant sind ja die sechs
enthaltung was auch immer dahinter
stecken mag in einer geheimen abstimmung
es wird schwierig genau es ist wie man
es auch nimmt man kann auch zum allen
sagen das ist ein schlechtes ergebnis
für den cdu vorsitzenden aus der eigenen
aus dem eigenen vorstand so ins rennen
geschickt zu werden man kann auf der
anderen seite sagen die erzählung der
spinnen die lautstärke mit der das lager
die letzten tage getrommelt hat war dann
doch nicht so oder lässt sich nicht über
einbringen mit dem ergebnis dass dann
wenn auch nicht hundertprozentig aber
klar für laschet aus der verein ist was
unterm strich bleibt ist dass laschet
sollte sie jetzt tatsächlich einlenken
das werden wir gleich sehen als
kanzlerkandidat ins rennen geht niemand
ist der von anfang an hundertprozentig
die zustellung seiner eigenen partei
hatte das ist ein großer mann los in den
bundestagswahlkampf klar
also da müsste laschet erst mal dafür
sorgen auch dass die eigenen reihen sich
sozusagen hinter ihnen dann auch wieder
schließen wir nehmen unsere user gerne
mit aslam schimborn fragt über youtube
an dich nicole guten mittag ich hätte
eine frage eben an genau dich denken sie
wenn jetzt armin laschet kanzler werden
würde das dann markus söder ein
ministerium von ihm bekommen könnte
villa das überhaupt
ein großes argument ein wichtiges
argument dass laschet für sich und seine
anhänger innen auch für ihn ins feld
geführt haben ist der versöhnende
charakter den armin laschet besitzt das
wäre also eine geste die durchaus für
ihn sprechen würde die frage ist aber
auch mdl markus söder sich da überhaupt
einräumen wollen würde er unter einem
kanzler da schnitt ein ministerium
übernehmen wollen wir sprechen hier von
einem großen ego das hat natürlich beide
sonst wird man nicht ministerpräsident
als wird man auch nicht parteichef aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das
sicherlich thema wird aber wie das dann
am ende ausgeht sollte darstellt
überhaupt kanzler werden auch ein großes
fragezeichen es ist ja im moment sowieso
an fast allem ein fragezeichen
ja das kann man wohl sagen wir nehmen da
noch ein paar kommentare mit unter
anderem von robbie witze über youtube ja
ist es etwas peinlich mit der union und
dem kampf der alpha männchen solche
stimmen haben wir in den letzten tagen
öfter gehört franz lämmler über facebook
ein politiker einer splitterpartei aus
dem alpenraum als kanzler gott bewahre
uns na ja gut also dass seine meinung
aber wir wollen eben noch mal schauen
auf die tage die letzten tage die der
vergangen sind eben nicht auf biegen und
brechen wollte die union dieses thema
der kanzlerkandidatur miteinander
entscheiden das ist so nicht gelungen
das kann man feststellen die aussagen in
den letzten tagen der beiden haben
gezeigt wie schwierig offenbar die
entscheidungsfindung dann doch war
markus söder und ich haben vor dem
heutigen tag ein langes gespräch
miteinander geführt
wir haben unsere bereitschaft erklärt
für die kanzlerkandidatur anzutreten
haben ihn hat in einem der interviews
letzten gezeigt und das fand ich wichtig
und auch beeindruckend es soll dann am
ende derjenige der kanzlerkandidat sein
der die besten wahlchancen für unser für
unsere gemeinsame idee hat die
bereitschaft von zweien liegt auf dem
tisch die aufgabenstellung liegt auf dem
tisch und jetzt werden wir diese
beratung morgen zunächst in der cdu und
der csu erleben es ist für beide wichtig
für armin und mich für uns beide dass
wir die entscheidung nicht auf biegen
und brechen fällen
wir haben verabredet dass das
cdu-präsidium heute keinen beschluss
fasst sondern dass wir ein meinungsbild
einholen und sie kennen alle die
erklärungen auch von markus söder am
gestrigen tag umfragen sind nicht alle
ist aber sie sind ein freundlicher
maßstab und sie sind auch eine
deutlicher hinweis darauf was die
bevölkerung denkt und wir können uns sie
nicht abkoppeln von der mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land wenn man hört
dass in der fraktion ist wohl großen
diskussionsbedarf gibt dann denke ich es
ist klug dass man nicht nur in einem
kleinen hinterzimmer entscheidet es war
eines bei allen dabei einigt euch
schnell gut schnell ist relativ jetzt
scheint es immerhin so zu sein dass nach
gut einer woche fast zehn tagen eine
entscheidung wohl fallen wird ja also da
waren jetzt mehrere aspekte dabei die
man vielleicht noch mal kurz beleuchten
kann unter anderem die breite
unterstützung von der ja auch markus
söder immer gesprochen hat bei der ja
ausdrücklich die basis mit einbezogen
hat also auch die umfragen so zu sagen
was ist da jetzt von armin laschet zu
erwarten wie wird er wohl versuchen
dieses problem was er ja hat dass er
eben in den umfragen nicht so gut
dasteht in den nächsten wochen wieder
wettzumachen und monaten
ich würde erstmal sagen das ist eine
kopfsache und wenn armin laschet wieder
einmal 1 bewiesen hat dann dass er
nerven hat wie drahtseile das wird jetzt
auch von denjenigen als argument als
begründung für das rückzug so er denn so
kommen sollte der sich andeutet seit
gestern als 1 1 ein grund dafür genannt
die sich auch mit söder und laschet
auskennen die sagen söder hat
anscheinend unterschätzt wie
willensstark und die nerven stark armin
laschet ist am lassek weiß dass er immer
schon in seiner karriere jemand gewesen
ist er unterschätzt wurde und am ende
der lachende sieger war also kaum jemand
hätte gedacht dass er
nrw-ministerpräsident wird und dann hat
er die wahl gewonnen dass zum beispiel
er dürfte im rückenwind geben und er
weiß wie schnelllebig die zeiten sind
wie schnell sich um fragen drehen können
erfährt dann immer wieder das beispiel
jens spahn an der jaaa ende letzten
jahres ein liebling in den umfragen war
und mittlerweile 8
abgestürzt ist also das wird er jetzt
nehmen um möglichst selbstbewusst
aufzutreten und eben versuchen wird
diese zuversicht auch zu übertragen auf
potenzielle wähler und wählerinnen will
boyle fragt uns über youtube gibt es
noch eine möglichkeit dass söder doch
der kandidat wird ist das schon völlig
ausgeschlossen oder wie schätzt du da
sein
jemand aus der cdu hat uns letzte woche
gesagt alles ist möglich und da war er
ziemlich genervt als er das gesagt hat
das heißt auf der anderen seite die
situation ist total unberechenbar und es
mal so zu übersetzen
also bevor es würde jetzt vor der kamera
nicht gesagt hat ich räume den weg ich
gebe abi laschet auch mein plazet er ist
jetzt der gemeinsame kandidat von cdu
csu würde ich so eine frage wieder mit
ja oder mit nein beantworten hat so hat
man jetzt schon zu viel erlebt in den
letzten tagen und wir warten immer noch
auf fernseher gucken vielleicht gerade
noch mal auf die situation vor ort da
ist immerhin eine tür aufgegangen aber
man wartet noch und deswegen warten wir
auch noch und machen entsprechend weiter
mit unseren usern defregger fragt über
youtube ist das vielleicht auch ein
zeichen dass cdu und csu getrennte wege
als bundes parteien gehen sollten es gab
ja auch aus der cdu stimmen in den
vergangenen tagen ja also wenn herr
söder sich nicht fügt dann überlegen wir
ob wir nicht mit der cdu in bayern
antreten
also wir erinnern uns mal an das jahr
2018 da waren wir hier in berlin auch
nicht ganz sicher ob jetzt nicht
tatsächlich ein bruch der
schwesterparteien bevorsteht das war in
der so genannten früchte
flüchtlingskrise da hat man sich wieder
zusammengerauft und das hat man auch
hier in den vergangenen tagen immer
wieder gehört dass das wirklich das
letzte ist was man möchte man weiß dann
was man aneinander hat und diese drohung
dann cdu ortsverbände in bayern zu
gründen die war auch nicht neu und so
ganz ernst genommen hat man das weder in
bayern noch wirklich in der cdu
sie fragt inwieweit würde sich der
sogenannte riss innerhalb der union auf
politischer ebene bemerkbar machen also
ich denke das sind zwei verschiedene
ebenen also es gibt zum einen vielleicht
jetzt den konflikten zwischen cdu und
csu aber auch eben innerhalb der cdu
das muss man natürlich auch noch
auseinanderhalten ganz genau das ist
total wichtig das noch mal zu sagen es
ist nicht nur ein streit zwischen den
schwestern beziehungsweise es sind nicht
nur zwei teilweise zeitweise wurde peter
te rivalen aus den jeweiligen
schwesterparteien sondern innerhalb der
cdu gestern abend hat ja nur der
bundesvorstand der cdu abgestimmt und
ein nicht so bambi das ergebnis für
laschet abgeliefert das heißt man wird
da in den nächsten monaten risse kitten
müssen ja auch innerhalb der cdu und
auch da ist eben fraglich wie viel
rückenwind hat dann laschet einmal in
der eigenen partei aber auch eben an der
basis ja bei den leuten die die plakate
kleben die den wahlkampf auf der straße
so er denn in den gründerzeiten möglich
sein wird dass das wird etwas sein diese
woche die zurückliegt die wird die union
die wird aber auch die cdu noch lange
beschäftigen
markus söder abgesagt würde armin
laschet wenn es dann würde zu 100
prozent unterstützen
gerade das was du gesagt hast mit dem
plakate geben ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass an der csu-basis die bereitschaft
und vor allem die hingabe plakate für
lasche zu kleben übersichtlich
ausgeprägt sein dürfte dürfte sie aber
wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass wir
alle mit hochgezogenen augenbrauen und
fassungslosem blick seit einer woche zu
sehen was da passiert weil das so
ungewöhnlich ist weil das eigentlich
etwas ist wofür cdu und csu auch immer
standen nämlich für disziplin für
nichtöffentlich ausgefochten im streit
das hat man bei der spd in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder auch
gesehen aus unionssicht und auch
teilweise süffisant aber auch teilweise
besorgt kommentiert und nun hat man sich
quasi selber dieses theater gegeben
die frage ist ob man jetzt ob das ein
heilsamer schock war und ob man jetzt zu
dieser alten disziplin zurückfindet und
sich sagt okay wir sind jetzt hier aus
csu-sicht die verlierer aber wir sind
immer noch die kleine schwester wie es
ist oder eben einmal gesagt hat und
jetzt packen wir alle mal zusammen mit
anders ist das ist etwas was wir in den
kommenden monaten beobachten werden mit
großem interesse ist das vielleicht auch
ein aspekt gewesen die die fallhöhe dir
doch sehr unterschiedlich war also armin
laschet hat man immer gesagt der kommt
ja im prinzip nicht unbeschadet raus
wenn er das nicht gewinn bei markus
söder hat man gesagt naja gut also er
hat jetzt zum guten auftritt hingelegt
und er kann ohne irgendwie an ansehen zu
verlieren
auch auf seinen alten posten im prinzip
zurück oder wie schätzt du das 1
das kann er aber die frage ist ja ob
markus söder sollte er heute zurück
ziehen für den rest seines lebens die
kanzlerkandidaten pläne die kanzler
plänen die ja jetzt begraben hat so als
ist ja noch nicht erkannt ja durchaus
noch mal versuchen deswegen das könnte
auch ein grund dafür sein dass er sich
jetzt gestern doch friedfertiger gegeben
hat als in den tagen zuvor
respektvoller und auch wie es eben schon
gesagt habe demütiger markus söder ist
jemand über den horst seehofer ehemals
ufer sitzen da mal gesagt hat er sei ein
mensch der zu spitzeleien neigt ja und
ich muss hier mal einmal gehören dich
aber noch schulden sind nicht gerade
nicht aber gehören dich so da erzählen
würde ich werde mich jetzt wieder näher
zur spitze leyen neigt und das ist ein
bild das kein politiker fand sich
gezeichnet haben möchte nicole wenn muss
endlich unterbrochen als jeder ist im
anmarsch und wir hören natürlich zu was
der csu parteichef zu sagen hat
ministerpräsident dr markus söder und
von csu-generalsekretär markus blume
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die würfel sind gefallen
armin laschet wird kanzlerkandidat der
union
mein wort das ich gegeben habe gilt seit
einer woche
wir haben ein angebot gemacht wir werden
bereit gewesen unserem land zu dienen
in der zentralen spitzenfunktion und
position der deutschen politik und wir
haben für dieses angebot unglaublich
viel zuspruch erhalten
ich bedanke mich da ausdrücklich dafür
bei vielen vielen orts und
kreisverbänden der cdu besonders
ich bedanke mich sehr bei
arbeitsgemeinschaft gerade bei den
jungen bei den modernen bei denen die
auf zukunft aus waren für ihre wirklich
überragende unterstützung
ich bedanke mich vor allem auch bei
vielen mutigen abgeordneten die entgegen
normaler partei solidarität sehr offen
gesagt haben was sie schätzen
ich bedanke mich auch bei nahezu allen
ministerpräsidenten die gerade den
letzten tagen auch noch mal
unterstützung gezeigt haben und ganz
besonders bei unglaublich vielen bürgern
bürgern unseres landes nicht nur aus
bayern
wir haben überall aus deutschland
zuspruch erhalten und selten so viel wie
ein csu oder bayern es eigentlich hier
bekommen hat und es hat mich gefreut
es hat mich bewegt und ich gebe zu
etliches auch gerührt
das hätte ich nicht gedacht deswegen war
die bereitschaft sich zu erklären
wichtig für mich ist aber klar es gibt
verantwortung für das land das wäre die
bereitschaft gewesen zu kandidieren
aber es gibt auch verantwortung für die
union nur eine geschlossene union kann
am ende erfolgreich sein
in unserer demokratie die wir leben die
nicht nur eine demokratie ist nach
ritualen des gestern so die modernität
auch erfordert ist es wichtig dass
parteien nicht nur diskutieren sondern
am ende auch zusammenfinden
wir wollen keine spaltung wir wollen
eine geschlossene gemeinschaft
sie haben wir das immer gesagt es gibt
kein kreuz 1976 und es gibt auch keinen
sommer 20 18
natürlich gibt es unterschiedliche
ambitionen und personen
aber für mich ist und war wichtig dass
wir als neue csu in diesen schwierigen
zeiten anstand und stil
zu einem grundprinzip dass die
gemeinsamkeit setzen ich habe gestern
gesagt und einige von ihnen haben mich
gefragt gilt es dann auch genau diese
frage die cdu muss entscheiden und wenn
sie entscheidet halten wir uns daran
dies habe ich gesagt und das gilt auch
die cdu hat gestern abend getagt und
entschieden und wir akzeptieren das und
ich respektiere ist ich habe ihn
angerufen und habe ihm gratuliert habe
ihm auch gesagt dass wir jetzt als csu
akzeptieren wir haben auch die volle
unterstützung angeboten als csu in
diesen wie ich glaube außerordentlich
schwierig im wahlkampf den es geben wird
und wir werden ihn ohne groll mit voller
kraft unterstützen das kann ich für mich
ganz persönlich aber ich glaube auch für
uns der csu sagen das werden wir tun
jetzt kommt es darauf an
zusammenzustehen und zusammen zu rücken
es wird sicher noch diskussionen geben
aber hier jedenfalls bei unseren beitrag
zum gemeinsamen erfolg leisten
es gibt tage der diskussion
es gibt tage der entscheidung das ist
jetzt passiert und danach ist es wichtig
gemeinsam in die zukunft zu schauen
deswegen wünsche ich auch im namen der
csu ganz persönlich armin laschet für
die schwierige aufgabe die vor ihm steht
viel erfolg und bietet wie gesagt noch
einmal die unterstützung der csu
herzlichen dank markus blume
ja meine damen und herren wir haben eine
entscheidung und das ist gut so
markus will das kandidatur sie war ein
angebot sie war ein angebot an die union
in unserer anhänger und dann unser land
ich habe gestern an dieser stelle gesagt
es war ein verdammt gutes angebot
markus söder hat in den letzten tagen
gezeigt welche zugkraft er für die union
entfalten kann
umso bedeutender ist nun dass er sich
wie wir gerade gehört haben in den
dienst der gemeinsamen sache stellt denn
eines ist klar wir bleiben bei dem und
das ist mir auch als general sehr
wichtig wir bleiben bei dem was die csu
unter markus wieder auszeichnet nämlich
klar im kurs und souverän im stil
ich habe gerade gesagt markus söder
begeistert und lassen sie mich ganz
persönlich sagen markus söder war
erkennbar der kandidat der herzen aber
in der demokratie und gerade auch in der
innerparteilichen demokratie entscheidet
etwas anderes nämlich am ende die
mehrheit deshalb respektieren wir das
ergebnis und deshalb ist armin laschet
der kanzlerkandidat der union
vielen dank und auf wiedersehen bis bald
also heute keine nachfragen bei diesem
presse statement vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz die kernaussage also das
wichtigste natürliche armin laschet wird
kandidat markus söder hat es bestätigt
er sagt sie haben viel zuspruch erhalten
für ihr angebot bedankt sich natürlich
dafür aber es gebiete jetzt die
verantwortung eben für die union dass
man jetzt die gemeinsamkeiten betonen
und keine spaltung weiter vorantreibe er
hat noch mal die volle unterstützung für
laschet zugesagt seitens der csu und der
generalsekretär markus blume sagt auch
es ist gut dass es eine entscheidung
gibt söder war der kandidat der herzen
aber die mehrheit habe sich anders
entschieden nicole was sagst du zu
diesem auftritt das war kurz und
schmerzlos mir keine fragen gestern als
anders als gestern da wurde da wurden
fragen noch zugelassen mann hatte dem
anscheinend nichts hinzuzufügen und
interessant war fand ich dass markus
söder der ein begnadeter rhetoriker ist
und die räder auch genießt sofort auf
den punkt kam also er begrüßte alle
anwesenden und sagte dann die würfel
sind gefallen armin laschet ist
kanzlerkandidat der union keine
hintertür und das führt mich noch mal
zurück zu der frage die wir noch vor dem
auftritt der beiden gerade erörtert
haben markus söder hat in den
vergangenen monaten viel mühe darauf
verwendet ein bild fand sich als
brutalen rücksichtslosen und teilweise
auch intriganten maschine zu
konterkarieren ja und hat sich gerade in
der krise als sehr verantwortungsbewusst
als staatsmännisch als der beschützer
der bürger in den seines landes bayern
zu geben und dieses bild hat in der
vergangenen woche noch einmal große
risse erfahren nämlich dadurch dass er
das ergeben zum beispiel parteigremien
ja cdu präsidium und cdu-vorstand die
sich der vergangene woche schon für
laschet ausgesprochen hatten
quasi als nicht aussagekräftig genug weg
gewischt hat was in der demokratie an
bemerkenswerter vorgang ist und kein
guter es könnte sein das habe ich
gestern bei seinem auftritt bei seiner
gestrigen pressekonferenz schon gedacht
dass dass er damit nicht zufrieden sein
konnte und eben auch mit blick auf die
zukunft
sich vielleicht auch gedacht hat mit so
einem image kann ich nicht mehr viel
mehr werden als das was ich bin und wir
haben es ja gerade gesehen er hat sich
jetzt zurückgenommen sagt stellt sich in
den dienst der partei der partei der
schwesterparteien man will keinen bruch
das hat er auch noch mal betont also
markus söder gibt sich geläutert
das stimmt und so wie du es jetzt du
schreibst ist das ja quasi eigentlich so
als ob er mit diesem pfund
dass er jetzt vielleicht dadurch auch
hat dadurch dass er sagt okay ich stelle
mich in den dienst der sache und auch in
den dienst der größeren schwester dass
er damit in zukunft vielleicht dann doch
nochmal wuchern können möchte zumindest
dass er da keinen schaden hinterlässt
genau also damit kann man natürlich ich
weiß nicht was markus söder vor hat
vielleicht weiß er dass im moment selber
nicht und schaut jetzt erstmal wieder
bundestagswahlkampf läuft und die zeit
danach aber natürlich kann man damit
besser woran als mit einem bild das man
abgegeben hat als jemand dem alles egal
ist bis auf das eigene fortkommen damit
lockt man niemanden an die urne und
lässt das kreuz neben seinem eigenen
namen machen oder neben der eigenen
partei es gibt noch eine verfahrensfrage
von troll muss laschet noch von der
partei bestätigt werden ähnlich wie bei
den grünen oder ist er nun endgültig
kanzlerkandidat wobei man sagen muss bei
den grünen das ist auch eine er formelle
abstimmung also da rechnet keiner damit
dass es der widerstand geben wird genau
und die haben es gerade gehört anlasses
kanzlerkandidat der union
da beißt die maus keinen faden ab er
wird es sein jetzt die frage von knoten
tanz kann es auch einfach sein dass
markus söder abgewartet hat ob es
berbalk oder habeck also bei den grünen
werden und laschet nur aufgrund von
berbalk den vortritt gelassen hat
interessante frage
er ist ja interessante frage ich würde
mich immer ich würde immer davor warnen
sich zu sehr in verschwörungen zu viele
absprachen zu verlieren gedanklich eher
so funktioniert das in der regel nicht
und
ich sage es mal so ich habe gestern von
niemandem gehört der außerhalb des
politikbetriebs steht dass er schon
etwas länger wusste wer ist bei den
grünen wird ich gehe davon aus dass man
auch in der union schon so eine ahnung
hatte und ich glaube nicht dass man so
ein theater ja im schlechtesten
wortsinne inszeniert wie die union das
vergangene woche getan hat um zeit raus
zu schlagen und zu gucken was machen
denn die grünen also das wäre das wäre
harakiri und das wäre völlig kopflose
harakiri dann noch die frage von liam
baumann könnte eine antreten laschet
auch der afd nutzen ja dass ich glaube
dass der afg im moment sowieso relativ
egal ist was bei den anderen parteien
passiert zum einen also zumindest bei
der union ich war vor zwei wochen auf
dem parteitag der afg in dresden
der feind der afg sind die grünen das
ganz klar definiert der feind der afg
sind die grünen das sagte parteichef
leuten
er sagte dort sie müssen eigentlich nur
die bilder müssen eigentlich nur zwei
parteiprogramme oder wahlprogramme lesen
unseres und dass der gründer alle
anderen sind egal die haben sich so
angeglichen dass ist völlig wurscht dass
das eine und das andere ist stichwort
parteitag die afg hat so viel mit sich
selbst zu tun
das hat man jetzt in rheinland pfalz
gesehen und in baden württemberg bei den
landtagswahlen da hat die afg nicht gut
abgeschnitten und offene flanken gebe es
ja die korona politik wird ja vielfach
kritisiert und die fehler sind ja zum
teil auch tatsächlich offenbar die afd
steckt tiefer denn je im parteiinternen
streit zwischen dem sogenannten
gemäßigten und dem sogenannten und
angeblich offiziell aufgelösten flügel
also den rechtsaußen zum teil der
rechtsextremisten in der partei die fdp
hat immer noch große sorge davor vom
bundesverfassungsschutz als als
gesamtpartei beobachtet zu werden
die anderen parteien sind im moment
nicht so relevant für die afg die müssen
sich erstmal selber zusammenraufen und
nachdem das reh aus der gestrigen
bundesvorstandssitzung der afg hören ist
man davon noch weit entfernt
nicole ich höre gerade wir können nach
münchen gehen ich hoffe wir sprechen
gleich nochmal weiter aber vorerst würde
ich gerne mit meinem kollegen alexander
pohl in münchen sprechen unter sehe ich
ihn auch schon alexander hallo
ja wir haben gerade markus söder gehört
das war jetzt für vermutlich die meisten
journalisten keine große überraschung
das ergebnis trotzdem wie hat er auf
dich gewirkt was war dein eindruck von
seinem statement
also mein eindruck war dass markus söder
hier nicht gerade euphorisch das
vorgetragen hat er hat verzichtet er hat
gesagt armin laschet ist der kanzler
kandidat von cdu und csu hat gesagt er
hat mit ihm telefoniert er habe ihm
gratuliert aber sehr euphorisch klang
das nicht und das ist eine stimmung die
wir aus der partei seit heute morgen
eigentlich auch schon hören seit heute
morgen ist eigentlich allen klar
besonders den abgeordneten in der
csu-fraktion dass es so kommt und die
blicke richten sich jetzt natürlich auf
die bundestagswahl
weil die abgeordneten müssen ja
wahlkampf machen und sie müssen vor
allem ihre wähler überzeugen und sie
müssen ihre wähler von armin laschet
überzeugen und das so scheint es mir
wird ein sehr schwieriges unterfangen
sein weil die skepsis innerhalb der csu
mit blick auf einen kanzlerkandidaten
armin laschet die ist schon sehr sehr
groß
jetzt ist die frage markus söder hat
gesagt wir werden ihn unterstützen das
hat ja gerade in einem presse statement
gesagt aber wie euphorisch das dann
wirklich wird das wage ich jetzt noch
mal zu bezweifeln also da könnte das
mobilisieren etwas schwierig werden so
möchte ich jetzt mal formulieren und
einschätzen
ja also was anderes als dass sie ihn
unterstützen würden kann ja eigentlich
auch nicht sagen zumindest nicht auch
vor dem hintergrund was wir gerade mit
nicole diekmann besprochen haben wenn er
vielleicht auch in zukunft noch mal auf
die cdu angewiesen sein sollte und da
auch keinen scherbenhaufen hinterlassen
möchte trotzdem es gab in den letzten
tagen ja die stimmen aus der csu die
sagen also für schüler müssen wir keinen
wahlkampf machen für laschet wollen wir
keinen wahlkampf machen das muss ich ja
jetzt dann doch ändern was ist gerade
schon angedeutet die frage aber jetzt
sei der akustisch nicht verstanden es
war gerade der ton weg sagen sie es
bitte nochmal es gab stimmen in den
letzten tagen aus der csu die sagten
also für markus söder müssen wir keinen
wahlkampf machen für laschet wollen wir
keinen wahlkampf
machen aber diese haltung muss sich
alles ändern na das wird so nicht
funktionieren da das ist richtig also
dass man sich auf den standpunkt zurück
zieht dass man keinen wahlkampf macht
das ist schlechterdings nicht
vorstellbar
aber es ist ja doch ein unterschied ob
man das gefühl hat dass die union mit
einem spitzenkandidaten antritt der auch
die wähler hier in bayern mobilisieren
kann oder ob das eben nicht der fall ist
und natürlich sie sagen es ja zu recht
markus söder wird vielleicht in zukunft
auf die unterstützung seiner
schwesterpartei angewiesen sein das ist
ein punkt der andere punkt ist aber dass
markus söder zunächst einmal jetzt
wieder voll bayern natürlich im blick
hat auch die landtagswahlen die hier
bald wieder stattfinden und ehrlich
gesagt meine einschätzung ist dass das
was jetzt gerade passiert ist was wir in
den letzten in der letzten woche erlebt
haben das rennen um die
kanzlerkandidatur auch wenn markus söder
jetzt zurückzieht wird er hier sehr
gestärkt aus dieser auseinandersetzung
hervorgehen und jetzt muss er diese
stärke nutzen um seine partei die csu
auch davon zu begeistern
für armin laschet wahlkampf zu machen
das ist ein ganz interessanter punkt
finde ich bei laschet war das anders
also wenn der jetzt zurückgezogen hätte
hätte man ihnen das als schwäche
ausgelegt voraussichtlich wenn er die
abstimmung verloren hätte sowieso bei
söder scheint das jetzt nicht so zu sein
vielleicht kannst du das gerade noch mal
erklären warum geht söder jetzt gestärkt
sogar aus dieser ganzen veranstaltung
heraus weil er die volle rückendeckung
aus seiner partei hatte also wie gesagt
wir haben ja heute mit den mit den
vielen csu abgeordneten gesprochen und
die haben natürlich das ergebnis dieser
dieses kampfes jetzt nicht geschätzt
oder gesagt wir hätten das markus söder
zugetraut aber das legen sie markus
söder nicht als schwächer aus im
gegenteil sie sagen es ist gut dass
markus söder seinen hut in den ring
geworfen hat er wäre der bessere gewesen
aus sicht der csu
und das haben die umfragen ja auch
gezeigt also darauf wird natürlich auch
immer wieder verwiesen
das ist ja nicht und nicht nur in bayern
die umfragen nicht nur in bayern sondern
eben auch in der cdu in den
kreisverbänden auf der linie der
ministerpräsident da hat es ja sehr
großen zuspruch für markus söder gegeben
und das wird jetzt eben auch benutzt und
da wird gesagt na ja
unser mann wer das stärke gewesen
insofern die cdu hat die falsche
entscheidung getroffen aber das ist
nicht so dass markus söder jetzt als der
schwächere dasteht sondern ganz im
gegenteil er stärkt er steht als
gestärkt da gut dann halten wir das
erstmal fest für den moment vielen dank
alexander pohl nach münchen wir sprechen
noch mal mit nicole diekmann und bleiben
vielleicht gerade noch mal bei diesem
aspekt stärke und schwäche also gehören
markus söder ist trotzdem gestärkt armin
laschet jetzt okay wir warten auf herrn
blume ja komm ich konnte dich hören ich
konnte alexander pohl auch gerade hören
ich dachte du hättest eine frage noch
weiter gestellt ok belastet ist gestärkt
das würde ich jetzt erstmal auch wieder
mit einem einer berühmten fragezeichen
versehen
ich glaube man muss diesen tag auch noch
abwarten es gibt heute noch eine
fraktionssitzung das ist das einzig
gemeinsame gremium von cdu und csu
da kann man noch mal gespannt sein wir
werden ja das sagt die erfahrung quasi
in echtzeit wieder gezittert zu kommen
aus dieser sitzung was da an
redebeiträgen kommt es zum höhepunkt
darf ja wohl ein haken wie muss man sich
das vorstellen die sitzen da und geben
dann eins zu eins raus was da besprochen
wird also das ist ja eigentlich auch
schwer vorstellbar aber so läuft sehr
offensichtlich so scheint es zu laufen
das ist der grund warum und ab und zu
dann doch wir erinnern uns es gab eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mitten in
corona zeiten als die lizenzen hoch
waren und wir alle angewiesen oder
gebeten wurden zu hause zu bleiben
möglichst die wurde in präsenz
abgehalten und genau diesen effekt
nämlich zumindest einzudämmen nämlich
dass ständig nach draußen sickern per
per handy an journalistinnen
das ist einfacher dadurch dass so
veranstaltungen wie eben auch gestern
abend die cdu vorstandssitzung digital
abgehalten werden man sieht ja nicht wer
alles noch mit im raum ist man sieht
nicht wer das handy in der hand hat und
man sieht nicht was dann mit hilfe des
handys sollte es doch jemand in der hand
haben ob jemand kennen die kreis spielt
oder ob eben jemanden von bild zeitung
oder welt das waren gestern die
tatsächlich die medien mit den mit den
meisten informationen ja ob dem gerade
wieder was zu gespielt wird und gestern
abend es hatte was ein public viewing
tatsächlich wenn man die sozialen medien
verfolgt hat ja interessante eigentlich
müssten alle die handys abgeben wie in
der schule nichts nach außen dringt für
uns allerdings auch schade
wir finden das ja auch ganz interessant
wenn wir da auf dem laufenden gehalten
werden
eine frage von cosmic fans über youtube
denken sie dass die cdu und csu sich
weiterhin arrangieren werden bzw völlig
hinter laschet stehen werden oder setzt
sich die zerfleischung fort man möge
sich jetzt vielleicht gerade mal
vorstellen dass die umfragewerte für
laschet weiter schlecht bleiben würden
vielleicht für die grünen oder für die
spd sogar hochgehen ist davon auszugehen
dass trotzdem alle in der union
stillhalten werden
das wäre nach den vergangenen jahren was
neues annegret kramp karrenbauer kann
glaube ich an geht davon singen was in
ihrer zeit als cdu-vorsitzende los war
wie oft sie da aus den eigenen reihen
wir erinnern uns auch von armin laschet
der er dann ins amt folgte kritisiert
worden ist und das war nochmal unter
anderen voraussetzungen annegret kramp
karrenbauer war nie kanzlerkandidatin
die ist vorher zurück getreten bevor sie
es überhaupt werden konnte aufgrund
massiver kritik die zum teil natürlich
also die aufrecht ich war ja keine frage
es ist genau es ist jetzt eine eine
frage der umfragewerte der tendenzen der
kommenden monate gehen die jetzt nach
oben oder gehen die noch weiter nach
unten
wie wird armin laschet performen wir
wissen ja er ist nerven stark kamen aber
auch schon bei anderen wie zum beispiel
erlebt oder auch bei markus lanz
da hatte er auftritte die ihn überhaupt
nicht gedient haben weil er emotional
war unvorbereitet fahrig und auch
unseren wirkte noch mal wir haben das
letzte mal vor drei jahren schon darüber
gesprochen zerbricht diese diese
gemeinschaft aus cdu und csu vor drei
jahren war das ein erbitterter streit
und dagegen nicht nur über acht tage wie
jetzt zwischen söder und laschet sondern
über monate das waren vor allem seehofer
und merkel die sich in der
flüchtlingsfrage überhaupt nicht einigen
konnten
da hat man sich wieder zusammen
auf da ging es auch noch nicht um eine
wiederwahl ins kanzleramt ja also dafür
spricht dass man natürlich weiterhin den
kanzler stellen möchte dagegen spricht
dass wirklich viel zerrüttet war in den
vergangenen tagen und auch sehr
erfahrene kollegin dann sagen so was
haben sie noch nie erlebt der ton der da
untereinander auch innerhalb der cdu
geherrscht habe so was hätten sie noch
nie erlebt das habe eine neue qualität
ja das ist ein interessantes thema da
könnte man wahrscheinlich noch abend
füllen darüber sprechen wie die union
vor allem die cdu in dieser situation
überhaupt geraten konnte dass das jetzt
so holprig alles vonstatten gegangen ist
hat natürlich auch mit der langen ära
merkel zu tun
wir lesen gerade noch mal ein paar
kommentare vorlauf fuhr wie youtube haha
wie subtile anläuft na gut nicht so
interessant das bezog sich auf söder
martin über youtube bei aller häme das
ist groß und fair von söder und lilo
tester schreibt über facebook selbst
stammwähler der cdu waren in großer zahl
gegen laschet und dabei hofft man doch
neue wähler hinzuzugewinnen
klar muss man jetzt abwarten aber ich
glaube nicht an eine starke cdu mit
laschet die partei hat dem druck von
schäuble und co gehorcht es wäre besser
gewesen die gegenstimmen ernst zu nehmen
ein pyrrhussieg für laschet
das ist jetzt eine etwas skeptische
sicht der dinge
laschet ist aber jetzt gefordert das
kann man denke ich sagen er muss jetzt
wirklich aufräumen und und ja er muss
jetzt versuchen die partei hinter sich
zu bringen
ja aber wenn laschet gefordert ist dann
liefert der normalerweise auch also der
hut ist ja dann angetreten
irgendwann mal um cdu-vorsitzender zu
werden was er mittlerweile ist und er
hatte gegen sich norbert röttgen und
friedrich merz und das war auch vorher
schon nicht so klar wer das rennen macht
und armin laschet hat eine tolle rede
gehalten wie dort der firma gestern
sagte unsere studioleiterin da in
nordrhein-westfalen in manila schütz
land eine fast perfekte rede und dabei
einen leicht leichten einen fröhlichen
gelösten eindruck gemacht und das ist
die stärke von armin laschet wenn er
weiß er muss jetzt liefern dann tut er
das
und wenn er in seinem leben mal liefern
musste dann jetzt nicole diekmann war
dass unsere hauptstadt korrespondentin
in berlin logischerweise vielen dank für
diese einschätzung schön dass du heute
wieder bei uns warst und uns hat eine
analyse unterstützt das vielen dank und
wir gehen noch mal zu meinem kollegen
alexander pohl in münchen der die
pressekonferenz von markus söder live
mitverfolgt hat also söder hat am ende
dann doch laschet jetzt den vortritt
gewährt das hatte er ja auch angekündigt
trotzdem man fragt sich bleiben da jetzt
atmosphärische verstimmungen zwischen
den beiden parteien unter anderem hat
auch alexander dobrindt sich geäußert
hat gesagt das verfahren sagt er das
hinterlässt doch fragezeichen
tja wie ist das zu bewerten jetzt aus
münchen was glaubst du
naja ich denke dass das verfahren
tatsächlich fragezeichen hinterlässt und
das ist auch das was wir von der csu
basis hören
man hört immer wieder na ja wie man die
basis so ignorieren kann und damit meint
man jetzt unter anderem die unions basis
als ganzes das frage man sich schon dass
das was wir immer wieder hören also der
verweis darauf dass praktisch die
entscheidung der gremien die das jetzt
entschieden haben nicht ausreicht nicht
ausreicht um klar um sicherzustellen
dass man wirklich einen
kanzlerkandidaten hat wird einem
kanzlerkandidaten ins rennen geht der
eine bundestagswahl auch gewinnen kann
und da kann ich nur noch mal sagen dass
die zweifel ob eines armin laschet
jedoch sehr groß sind und die frage wird
sein und die aufgabe für markus söder
als parteichef wird auch sein
die csu so zu mobilisieren dass sie eben
einen engagierten wahlkampf hier für
armin laschet auch führt also markus
söder kann jetzt demnach dann zeigen wie
gut er auch versöhnen kann dass er
polarisieren kann das haben wir in der
vergangenheit schon öfter erlebt
genau das wird jetzt die große aufgabe
sein
die letzte woche war sehr reibungsfrei
das wurde hier auch so gesehen das wurde
in teilen der cdu als zerstörerisch
empfunden und man kann sich schon die
frage stellen warum man die lösung die
man jetzt gewählt hat nicht schon acht
tage vorher hätte haben können
und man hätte der union vielleicht
einiges erspart markus
söder steht auf dem standpunkt dass er
sagt diese woche der diskussion die war
sehr hilfreich
jetzt wisse jeder wo er steht die
aufgabe jetzt besteht aber darin die
schützengräben die in diesen acht tagen
ausgehoben wurden jetzt schleunigst
wieder zuzuschütten damit man eben
geschlossen in diesem wahlkampf gehen
kann der so hat das markus söder heute
auch gesagt sicherlich sehr schwer
werden wird vielleicht eine
abschlussfrage markus söder rein
körperlich der ist gefühl zwei köpfe
größer als armin laschet hatte ihn
vielleicht unterschätzt am ende
ich denke dass er ihnen ein wenig
unterschätzt hatte ich glaube dass
markus söder unterschätzt hat wie z
armin laschet am ende das aussitzt und
sagt na gut dann lasse ich eben auf eine
entscheidung ankommen er hat sozusagen
mit der strategie dass er nicht locker
lässt das eher zermürben will eigentlich
damit hatte markus söder am ende keinen
erfolg und da hat er armin laschet
sicherlich ein stück weit unterschätzt
ja das kann man so sagen
das ergebnis haben wir jetzt vielen dank
alexander pohl danke auch noch mal nach
münchen für diese einschätzung wir
wollen noch mal reinhören was denn der
csu-chef was markus söder heute genau
gesagt hat bitteschön
für mich ist aber klar es gibt
verantwortung für das land das wäre die
bereitschaft gewesen zu kandidieren
aber es gibt auch verantwortung für die
union nur eine geschlossene union kann
am ende erfolgreich sein
wir wollen keine spaltung wir wollen
eine geschlossene gemeinschaft ich habe
ihn angerufen und habe ihm gratuliert
habe ihm auch gesagt dass wir jetzt als
csu akzeptieren wir haben auch die volle
unterstützung angeboten als csu in
diesen wie ich glaube außerordentlich
schwierig im wahlkampf den es geben wird
und wir werden ihn ohne groll mit voller
kraft unterstützen das kann ich für mich
ganz persönlich aber ich glaube auch für
unsere csu sagen das werden wir tun
jetzt kommt es darauf an
zusammenzustehen und zusammen zu rücken
es wird sicher noch diskussionen geben
aber wir jedenfalls wollen unseren
beitrag zum gemeinsamen erfolg leisten
und daran wird er jetzt wohl gemessen
werden der markus söder also die
entscheidung ist gefallen
armin laschet wird kanzlerkandidat der
union und das war unser live stream
vielen dank für eure
heiligung eure fragen eure kommentare
und bis zum nächsten mal